that I did Arad started on Saturday and
if you're not familiar with the Iditarod
you know it's um
Alaska Alaska day I think if you up
there long enough you get a little
probably lazy you know or just snowed in
and so you hire a [ __ ] bunch of dogs
to pull you across the continent and
these dogs man these are some real
Wolf's dogs Wolf's probably a [ __ ]
skinny bear with a big nose you know all
kind of animals a [ __ ] fox that's on
HGH who knows what they're did what they
you know what Mother Nature is serving
up there
I mean Alaska is like the like the
icebox it's a it's like the freezer
section of a mayor of the really of
America and the world think about it
your memory when you in the grocery you
in regular sections you're walking
around and got the Ritz crackers you
know somebody put a thing of pickled
cabbages or something little you know
those little um what does it call with
the butter fingers they got those
beautiful I [ __ ] used to [ __ ] eat
a Butterfinger right when I get to the
grocery boy dude if I ain't buying this
[ __ ] son of meat and I'm hiding a
wrapper under a couple cabbages over
there by the produce areas but here's
what I'm saying is remember when you're
walking through the grocery everything's
casual they got them some more you know
those are you know with the arm with the
little guys that live in the trees the
arm and then cab Laureles boy dem
crackers they've got them little
crackers they got the raisins Raisinets
some other [ __ ] came out with
Raisinets do you know a feminist
probably couldn't handle raisins just
doing their thing because they used to
have a little dance team and stuff on
television and somebody came out with
raising nets and that's some bad [ __ ]
in a bag right there and they ain't
[ __ ] around but but anyway you
cruisin through everything is warm it's
comfortable cozy and
you get to the freezer section do you
could lose a friend in the [ __ ]
freezer section of the grocery room when
you were kid and you walk in and you're
like suddenly your mom opens that thing
as I walk you don't know what's going on
you can't remember who both your parents
are your eyes don't work that good your
[ __ ] shoulders turn all red you get
nervous and just because your mom wants
to get a couple of second fish sticks
and it's do this crazy back in there in
the freezer section man anything they
got you know and you hope it's ice cream
but it's not your mom's getting them
teriyaki meals over there some [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know lean Gene Okerlund
cuisine you know these little 60
calories and it look it's served in the
damn half of a [ __ ] Space Shuttle the
thing just you know everything got does
that Zekey sauce on it and you're losing
your [ __ ] mind bro that freezer
section make you do it oh I would I
would put on a couple coats before I go
on into the frozen food area when you're
a kid and you reach over they just have
that big part with the big turkeys and
the chickens in there that [ __ ] used to
be freezing when I was a kid now it's
like safety precautions and this and
that and you know the dead animals don't
even like to be at real cold
temperatures because they little [ __ ]
but when I was young man him turkey
doesn't thing was that four degrees in
there you reach over there and catch one
of the butterball hitters did I remember
I turned there ever one time one of the
turkey had been you know it was dead it
was like man [ __ ] cold
damn they serving him up but the
Iditarod is that they put these cold
dogs out there and these [ __ ]
run to a fire they put a fire you know I
mean it's a thousand mile race do they
put a thought they put a fire a thousand
miles from these dogs and they so they
so cold they'll run to that [ __ ] and
there's 52 teams 14 dogs on each team
do you know I'd be that dog out there at
night tryna bug boy waking up the other
dogs you know I'm sayin rolling a little
[ __ ] pork cutlet over by a little
wall you know maybe by a little one you
know a Weimaraner or something you get
that bad [ __ ] kid you know they got a
couple female German Shepherds out there
and they say into some wild [ __ ] I've
seen them on the Internet and off we're
gonna roll a pork cutlet over there with
my chin give that [ __ ] that cutlet you
know and then I you know while she's
giving it while she's enjoying that
cutlet I give her that rib you feel me
you know what I'm saying that 31st rib
baby that wiener but it takes nine days
apparently it starts in Willow Alaska it
finishes in Nome Alaska
it takes nine days $50,000 for the
winter and and I bet that's pretty
exciting you know if I were somebody who
was crazy I would hide some hamburger
meat in the snow and watch the whole
[ __ ] race go AWOL son did you hide a
[ __ ] um one of those water burgers in
there dude a dog will go probably at
least 200 yards off track for a Down
water burger well thanks for watching
that video right there that was a
beautiful little segment I think but of
course i'm partisan to myself but you
can move on to another video right now
you can check on this video or on this
video that's two different options and
you can also subscribe to the channel
check on a new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe subscribe